>>I made this in color.
The wall, and the letters
in red to kind
of represent the blood that's
been spilled over there.
>>Narrator: Whether they are
presenting their portfolio
of artwork..
>>Teacher: See, the
pressure launches this out.
>>Narrator: Or using a spud gun to
test a projectile motion equation
for a pre-calculus project,
>>Teacher: Before we shoot it,
we're able to calculate
how far it's going to go.
>>Narrator: YES Prep North
Central students do things
with the knowledge they acquire.
>>Teacher: That's close,
that's close.
>>Michelle: In terms of
ensuring rigor, it's a question
that we've always struggled with,
and I hope we always continue
to struggle with, because I
never want any of our instructors
to be satisfied with the level
of rigor, I want us always
to be thinking of ways that we
can push the kids more and more.
>>Teacher: And if this is where
Christopher Columbus landed,
then what can we guess,
or what can we assume?
>>Narrator: YES Prep North Central's
recipe for academic rigor includes,
integration of core subjects
to deepen understanding,
inquiry based project learning
to show real world relevance,
assess student work in a
holistic and comprehensive way,
and empower the students to become
self-reflective critical thinkers.
>>Teacher: At 90 and 270, if you have
a quarter moon, it shouldn't look
like a crescent at all,
it should look like--
>>Narrator: In sixth and seventh
grades, core subjects are integrated.
Math, science a technology
are team taught in one block,
while language arts and
humanities are taught in another.
>>Luis: Hi, my name is Lou Salazar,
and this is a project that we did.
It's called books of hope.
>>Narrator: In a cross-curricular
arts and humanities project,
seventh graders researched,
wrote and published books
on their favorite subjects to ship
to a sponsored school in Uganda.
>>Luis: And here I have,
in order, all the process
that I took, to make this book.
>>Katie: We taught them
how to write nonfiction,
and this took about a month
and a half, where they went
through this writing process.
The whole time, we kept reminding
them, you know, why we're doing this,
and what these books are
going to be used for,
and we found that the kids
were just incredibly motivated.
They really, really latched onto this
vision that we had, and they wanted
to make them perfect, because
they knew that kids were going
to be learning from them.
>>Luis: And I really didn't want
to focus on one specific culture,
because I thought it was better
for people to relate to it
if I made it, and a lot of cultures.
>>Michelle: We're a project based
school, so the students are asked
to do things that are going to really
challenge them to think critically.
>>Luis: And we had to revise
it ourselves, and then we had
to give it to the teacher.
>>Teacher: It excites them, so
they always talk about projects
and they're really
excited to do them,
because of those relevant
connections.
>>Luis: It's a good thing to do, like
to do service, help other people,
not because they tell you
to, it's good, because, like,
you want someone, like, for example,
these books, I really put effort
on it, I didn't put a lot of effort
for the grade, I put a lot of effort
so the kids in Uganda could learn.
>>Rachel: Okay, I need you to
take out your rubrics quickly.
>>Narrator: YES Prep uses a
variety of assessment tools
to track student progress.
>>Student: I wrote three sonnets.
>>Rachel: The piece
that we're working on is
to make a literary analysis paper, so
that was kind of the main assessment,
but then we also had some
creative outlets for them,
where they created their own sonnets,
or a lot of people made poems,
or raps, or you know, just
visual representations,
just to show their
artistic expression.
>>Student: What means
the world to you?
Being lost for a guy, or
being lost for a girl.
To the world, you just mean somebody,
but to somebody you mean the world.
>>Narrator: To empower students to
take charge of their own learning,
the grading process is
completely transparent.
The students are given
assessment rubrics at the beginning
of each project, so the
expectations are clear.
>>Kristy: You can get a
just beginning, which is,
you didn't put effort in it,
and you just slacked off
during the whole time.
Approaching, is when
you put some effort,
but it's like she could tell
you did it at the last minute.
Meets, is you met her expectations
on what she wanted you to do.
You did a very good job, and Exceeds,
is, you went above and beyond, like,
you created something that she
didn't even tell you to create.
It's really easy to get an exceeds,
because you already know
what's expected from you.
>>Student: The other AOI
I chose was environment.
>>Narrator: Performance
assessment is used in every grade,
so by the time they
reach high school,
YES Prep students are
experienced presenters.
>>Katie: To have them actually
verbally articulate their learning,
I think is a hugely important skill,
and one that our seventh graders
and sixth graders really need
to practice, so they feel sort
of the importance of, like, oh, you
know, my parents are going to come,
and ask me questions, and
other teachers are going
to ask me questions.
And so they tend to be a little
more motivated about the project,
so that they're more prepared.
>>Teacher: Please just
really give a lot of thought
and introspect into this.
>>Narrator: Each spring, all students
must not only defend their knowledge
of the core content, but prove
that they are adding value
to the school and the community.
>>Student: Like, math
has always taught me
that there's always more
ways to solve one problem.
And I can relate that to life.
>>Michelle: They're
asked to think critically
about what they've learned, the
skills that they've acquired,
and then, on top of that, we want
them to think about themselves
as people, and how they've changed.
>>Student: Comparing it to
the beginning of the year,
I think I've improved
my communication.
>>Narrator: Critical thinking is
a key skill for college readiness,
and every person in the building is
working towards getting every student
into college.
>>Teacher: So you have
to work a little harder?
>>Student: Yeah.
And--
>>Teacher: And you do.
>>Student: And I do.
>>Narrator: But the hard work is
carried out with joy and passion.
>>But the school is serious
and fun at the same time,
because we have awesome teachers, who
make class fun, and put a whole bunch
of work into the lessons and
make sure you get it deep
through your head, and make sure
that you have fun with it, too.
>>Luis: They prepare us for
college, so like, it's really hard.
It's really hard, like,
they're very challenging.
I really like it, because they
really care about your education,
and it's a good experience
being at YES.
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.